bonsoir
alexis poulain merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france les nouvelles ne
sont pas réjouissantes un an jour pour
jour après le premier confinement strict
emmanuel macron et ils acculent est
forcé de changer de stratégie alexis oui
c'est à dire que l'on se demande après
tout s'il a vraiment une stratégie
rappelez-vous emmanuel macron il y a
quelques semaines devant un jeune lors
d'une de ses visites il disait on doit
tenir bon ensemble encore quatre à six
semaines
et puis hier et nous annonce que c'est
le virus qui est le maître du temps le
maître des horloges et que c'est
finalement pas lui qui décide alors il
ya une stratégie sur et qui est toujours
la même pour une heure là qu'on sait que
c'est jamais sa faute c'est toujours la
faute des autres
alors oui l'aveyron a accusé astrazeneca
qui ne livre pas assez de doses à seneca
bien sûr sous le feu des critiques un
vaccin qui a été suspendue dans plus
d'une quinzaine de pays européens on
attend bien sûr la l'autorité de la
santé européennes pour savoir si on va
continuer la vaccination ou pas mais le
mal est fait il ya vraiment une
politique de gribouille depuis le début
c'est à dire que on savait qu'il y avait
des variants depuis très tôt le
professeur à ou en parlait dès le mois
de septembre dans wii a encore navires
us ça évolue ça fait des variants est
aujourd'hui jean castex nous parle d'une
troisième vague nous parle de
potentiellement re confiné encore une
fois une nouvelle région et ce serait
l'île de france on a tout fait pour
l'éviter et on voit bien que emmanuel
macron a tout fait pour éviter ce
confinement mais de manière politique
pas de manière sanitaire qu'il n'y a
aucune coordination que le dimanche
qu'on dit qu'on n'a pas de doute sur
astrazeneca et puis que le lundi on dit
qu'on a des doutes et qu'on finalement
suit la politique allemande parce que
ces quelques minutes après le choix de
angela merkel de suspendre le vaccin
astrazeneca kemal macron fait le suiveur
et décide de suspendre à son tour alors
il reçoit les critiques de certains
soignants qui disent mais attendez vous
avez envoyé un ces flacons de vaccin
astrazeneca aux pharmaciens et aux
médecins qui sont prêts à vacciner
que va-t-il se passer et les et on voit
bien que ce qu'est ce qu'il se passe
les français qui étaient prêts à se
faire vacciner qui
commence à avoir des doutes et qui
décide finalement de ne plus vouloir
recevoir ce vaccin astrazeneca
ils ne sont plus que 20 % contre plus de
50% il y a seulement deux jours donc on
est dans une stratégie du doute
permanent de la responsabilité
irresponsables ou ce n'est jamais la
faute du responsable politique mais
toujours la faute des autres
emmanuel macron a vu tout à l'heure les
responsables du conseil sanitaire des
réanimateurs demain matin un conseil de
défense
on est suspendu au choix du roi c'est ça
depuis un an alors dans le même temps
alexis la marge de manoeuvre du
gouvernement et des manuels macro est de
plus en plus réduite il faut bien le
dire oui mais c'est un choix encore une
fois du responsable premier le
responsable des institutions mails
macron le locataire de l'élysée
l'épidémiologiste en chef qui a décidé
de choisir cette voie étroite pour ne
par confiner à tout prix alors on a eu 1
les confinements du week-end on a eu le
couvre feu de 18h des mesures qui pose
question sur leur efficacité puisqu'on
est à 300 morts par jour en mt quarante
mille morts en quatre mois tous ces
morts-là sont comptables de cette
politique sanitaire qui n'en est pas une
derrière on a demandé aux forces de
l'ordre de mettre des amendes à 18h de
faire respecter les gestes barrières sur
les quais de seine et et ailleurs est en
réalité on avait un an pour préparer
finalement cette deuxième set 3 et mal
finalement pour faire que la france soit
résilient sur le plan sanitaire qu'est
ce qu'on a fait on a continué de fermer
des lits en ile de france on a continué
de ne pas former des soignants on a
évité de parler des traitements on a
misé tout sur les vaccins et ses vaccins
aujourd'hui font défaut à la fois en
nombre de doses est à la fois dans leur
qualité
donc qu'est ce qu'il reste rien cette
voie étroite qui a été donnée un parrain
et marraine macron s'avère est un
cul-de-sac
on se retrouve un an après exactement au
même point qu'en mars 2020 c'est une
fatigue permanente c'est une confiance
et rodez dans le gouvernement je crois
qu'aujourd'hui plus personne finalement
n'accorde de crédit à la parole des
responsables politiques qui ont choisi
de gérer cette crise sanitaire de
manière politique de manière liberticide
et non pas de manière sanitaire
n'écoutant pas les soignants qui
demandait dès janvier de confiner pour
éviter ce pic du mois de mars
donc on est là dans la responsabilité
totale du chef de l'état qui a choisi
une à choix politiques alors ces lois
blain il l'a fait maintenant qu'ils
l'assument
c'est pas le cas si pour l'heure la
bataille de la confiance est elle perdue
oui je viens de l'évoquer je pense que
la bataille de la confiance est
totalement perdu à la fois dans cette
campagne de vaccination qui a peiné à
arriver à un certain niveau
elle a commencé lentement elle a pris
après un peu plus de vitesse et puis on
patatras arrive le cas astrazeneca et là
c'est thrombose veineuse particulière
des morts à ces jeunes au sein des
pompiers des infirmières en autriche et
on suspend en disant on reprendra la
vaccination
mais entre la suspension et la reprise
de la vaccination c'est des milliers
voire des millions de français qui vont
douter qu'ils vont refuser finalement ce
vaccin en disant je préfère attendre de
savoir ce qu'il en est parce que ces
vaccins sont encore finalement dans une
phase exploratoire
rien n'est sûr après tout les études qui
ont permis de les mettre en urgence sur
les marchés se sont faits sur quelques
milliers de personnes
et là on vaccine des millions de
personnes donc forcément arrive ddca
qu'il n'était pas prévu lors des
premières études et puis la confiance
dans ce gouvernement depuis un an je
crois que elle est totalement erroné
puisque il n'y a pas de cap clair on a
un commissariat au plan qui est en train
de plancher sur la démographie au lieu
de plancher sur la planification
sanitaire
depuis un an je le disais on aurait pu
choisir d'ouvrir des lits aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'on fait on déplace les
malades dans des transports sanitaires
qui coûtent une fortune qui certes
permettre de sauver délit mais à quel
prix alors qu' on aurait pu organiser
dans des bassins où la densité de
population est importante à voir
davantage de lits à davantage de
soignants plutôt que d'envoyer des
patients parisien vers bordeaux ou
ailleurs tout ça n'a aucun sens et les
moyens n'ont pas été mis pas plus que
sur la recherche et pleura thouars
d'autre solution que les vaccins on a
misé à 100% sur la vaccination
aujourd'hui
astrazeneca est le premier vaccin qui
font défaut qu'en sera-t-il de johnson &
johnson qu'en sera-t-il de plaisir
aujourd'hui tout le monde veut du trésor
mais peut-être que en face aux variants
pfizer sera inefficace ou moins
efficaces et là pas de plan b
depuis un an on fait du surplace voire
même on veut en arrière et la confiance
dans le politique n'a fait que perdre et
reculer encore davantage
merci alexis coulon puisque vous parliez
de confiance et de l'astra zeneca sachez
que pour rassurer jean castex a affirmé
ce soir qu'il se ferait vacciner très
rapidement si le feu vert d'astrazeneca
été à nouveau donnée par les autorités
européennes
voilà merci alexis poule a est dit on a
eu cette phrase et décale donc oui mais
voilà bas et côté en tout cas une
réunion a lieu jeudi au sein de l'europe
pour la suite à donner effectivement à
ce vaccin astrazeneca suspendu je vous
le rappelle donc dans 7 pays merci à
vous alexis poulain